[Music]
if you ever thought president Donald J
Trump's popularity success or occupancy
in the White House was attributable to
his billions take a look at the
presidential wannabe Michael Bloomberg
and think again now on the surface Trump
and Bloomberg might appear similar both
New York City strong-willed billionaires
each wanting to be President in 2020 but
the similarities and their the
obituaries written after Bloomberg's
disastrous horrifying and embarrassing
performance at the Nevada Democratic
base tell the story now most people
outside of New York City don't know who
Michael Bloomberg is and after watching
the debate I'm not sure even he knows
who he is once a Democrat then a
Republican then an independent and now a
Democrat in order to run for president
the van is so wishy-washy and spineless
that he doesn't just flip-flop he
flip-flops and then backflips without
any logical rational explanation other
than political expediency as a result he
has single-handedly managed to alienate
just about everyone he needs in his
quixotic effort to become president
consider the following now there are at
least 40 separate work discrimination
and sexual harassment cases that he has
settled at his company
all of them sealed by a nondisclosure
agreement preventing the women from
speaking to her credit elizabeth warren
like a high school principal dressing
down a juvenile went up one side of
Bloomberg and down the other
take a look mr. mayor are you willing to
release all of those women from those
non-disclosure agreements so we can hear
their side of the story
none of them accuse me of doing anything
other than maybe they didn't like the
joke I told and let me just there's a
agreements between two parties that
wanted to keep it quiet and that's up to
them they sign those agreements and
we'll live with it
well apparently his handlers decided he
could live with it and that his muzzling
and then refusing to release the women
from these agreements would not stand so
according to the Washington Post though
Bloomberg has four years battles women's
allegations of profane sexist comments
as he ran a company where the culture of
sexual harassment and degradation of
women appeared to be pervasive the most
high-profile case from a former sales
woman who sued Bloomberg alleging he
told her to quote kill it when he
learned she was pregnant The Post's
interviewed a former employee who
witnessed that very conversation now
that kind of behavior has managed to tee
off a lot of women in America and then
there's stop and frisk
Bloomberg has since apologized for using
stop and frisk at the time he was mayor
managing to alienate just about all of
law enforcement and those who believe
that if handled correctly stop-and-frisk
was an effective crime-fighting tool but
he was so unprepared for this question
that is a particular interest to the
african-american community and that he
must court in his bid to be President
that he stumbled and acted as though he
never even expected the question well if
I go back and look at my time in office
the one thing that I'm
really worried about embarrassed about
was how it turned out with stop and
frisk and by the way in that landmark
decision Terry versus Ohio the United
States Supreme Court with Justice
Thurgood Marshall joining the majority
ruled that the Fourth Amendment
prohibition on unreasonable searches and
seizures is not violated under
stop-and-frisk
if the officer has a reasonable
suspicion that the person is involved in
criminality and that he may be armed but
you know mayor what you should be even
more worried about is the fact that you
believe that the way to get guns out of
kids hands is to throw them up against
the wall and frisk them and that 95% of
murders fit one MO you think you can
just take a description Xerox it and
pass it out to all the cops and then you
say that you're trying to understand
race issues by talking to quote a bunch
of african-american clergy and business
people you sat down with a bunch of
african-american clergy to figure this
out but the shame of this is this is the
one signature accomplishment that you
continued from the Rudy Giuliani
administration where lives were actually
saved now because of political
expediency you disavow yourself of this
and say if you had to do it over again
you would not do stop and frisk
essentially saying you'd go back to the
pre Giuliani homicide rate of 2500 New
York City victims a year and then there
are the farmers and the factory workers
take a look at this
I could teach anybody even people in
this room so no offense intended to be a
farmer
you it's a process see you dig a hole
you put up the seed in you put dirt on
top add water up comes the corn then we
had 300 you could learn that then
you have 300 years of the industrial
society you put the piece of metal on
the lathe you turn the crank the
direction of the arrow and you can have
a job what what you just said is one of
the most insanely idiotic things I have
ever heard at no point in your rambling
incoherent response were you even close
to anything in this room is now Dumber
for having listened to it I award you no
points and may God have mercy on your
soul I agree need I remind you mr. mayor
you're running as a Democrat in the most
liberal progressive leftist bunch of
presidential candidates in American
history and you cannot exhibit or
articulate blatant transphobia quote if
your conversation during a presidential
election is about some guy wearing a
dress and whether he/she or it can go to
the locker room with their daughter
that's not a winning formula for most
people close quote
okay smarty-pants so far you managed to
tee off the women the african-americans
farmers factory workers law enforcement
the LGBTQ community now is there anyone
left oh yes if you're 95 and you need
medical care we probably shouldn't have
to give it to you since according to
Bloomberg it's not really cost-effective
get it and how about family members of
the victims of one of the greatest hate
crimes in our nation's history you try
to make it look like you were mayor of
the city of New York on 9/11 and by the
way you weren't Rudy Giuliani was but
you made sure although the city charter
allows for just two terms you bought
your way into a third term
I suspect you might even try to do the
same
were you to be elected president which
by the way will never happen and by the
way speaking of 9/11 you're on tape
telling the widows of the victims killed
that day to quote suck it up and move on
and finally then there's another kind of
small category guns that pretty much
alienates everyone else in the country I
have guns hand guns long guns as do many
many Americans
we're law-abiding citizens and we're not
responsible for what some criminal does
with his or her gun but you mr.
Bloomberg want to do everything in your
power to take away those guns I Got News
for you it ain't gonna happen and I
understand you're plotting a strategy
for a brokered convention smart seeing
it you haven't won a single delegate you
can't answer a single question you've
got huge negatives you're an elitist you
were the biggest loser at the highest
watch debate and Democrat history and
might I add you spent over four hundred
million dollars to get Americans to know
you and you came out on stage and blew
it almost as soon as you showed up might
I suggest a new debate team or a
personality change you certainly can't
afford it and that's my open let me know
what you think on my facebook and
twitter hashtag judge Janine